comme chaque matin à 9 heures les
audiences sont tombés tf1 dès miser sur
sam sa série dramatique qui en est à sa
cinquième saison et le public semble
avoir adhéré à cette idée puisque les
téléspectateurs étaient hier soir 4,5
millions devant leur écran web un super
nom mais partout de son côté france 2
avait également misé sur la fiction avec
les sandales blanches un téléfilm dans
lequel amel bent faisait ses premiers
pas en tant que comédienne
un film plébiscité par 3 1 millions de
personnes soit 13 5% du public
c'est bien mais ça peut être mieux
france 3 est sur la troisième marche du
podium avec secrets d'histoire et ses
deux millions de fidèles je suis heureux
de vous retrouver
depuis cette cité royale de loches suivi
par m6 qui avec l'émission opération
renaissance produite présentes et
réalisé par karine le marchand n'a
attiré pour sa dernière que 1,6 million
téléspectateurs
ah ouais d'une audience très décevante
pour la chaîne qui n'a pas réussi à
tirer son épingle du jeu avec cette
émission autour de l'obésité sap a pris
un set émission malheureusement ça n'a
pas pris
et il ya eu il ya eu une petite
polémique lien il ya eu des critiques
sur quelqu'un que j'adore sur christina
cordula qui fait partie de l'émission
est ce que vous comprenez les critiques
c'est l'une des causes du programme
élite cristina cordula elle s'est fait
clasher s'est fait tacler hier par les
autorités choqué par son attitude envers
les participantes
on a préparé une petite copine de
christina hier soir dites nous si vous
avez été choqué ou bavard christina
isabelle morini-bosc oui moi ça me
choque pas passionnant mais je comprends
c'est choqué parce qu'elle est tellement
identifié un programme que du coup dans
l'émission elle avait l'air d'être un
oeuf sur lumière explique juste à elvis
elvis est quelqu'un les rails sur m6
elle a cédé depuis très longtemps à quoi
elle a été convoquée un matin au niveau
d'avoir un cdi ça fait depuis 85 ans
qu'elle travaille l'ama
ça veut dire n'a pas compris que si la
virile doivent fermer la boîte tellement
le coude d'oseille un rail est pas et
elle encore peur d'eux vous pouvez en
dire
la place chanzy du féminin fond à fond
il faut tout réapprendre est ce que tu
aimes cette personne qu'elle a non si tu
n'aimes pas tu vas manger tue wagon ciré
geboers si je mets des tests et je mange
et c'est une boule de neige le pire que
je déteste et mon ventre
le truc qui tombe un tablier c'est
horrible alalalala audrey était pas
ainsi avec toi
possible riesch peut pas rester comme ça
[Musique]
ce
je fasse quelque chose je peux pas
rester comme ça voilà
il faut faire quelque chose à l'équipe
de change face aux élites serait bien en
maïs et ton corps il n'est pas gai nez
ça ne fait pas ce qu'est la robe elle
est mignonne
si christina allez à bientôt avait le
courage ma belle oui kelly bah pour moi
crise n'a quant à lui elle est styliste
à aucun moment on ne dit qu'elles
étaient psychologue qu'elle était
prologis au niveau de la santé au niveau
du mental voyons la dore n'y a pas de
souci mais pour moi c'est une styliste
donc focale habille les gens mais elle
n'est pas là pour mettre les gens devant
un miroir pour les conseillers ou quoi
que ce soit un diplôme pour ces acteurs
sont nicolas pernikoff exactement je go
sont mis alors à soit un risque évident
mais ce qui est bizarre c'est
effectivement de l'avoir mis à je pense
que c'est une erreur stratégique en
avoir mis là c'est comme s'il avait
décidé de mettre julien courbet ou
stéphane plaza l'apparition année c'est
pas ça se joue à vide a raison mais je
comprends pas ce qui a été stephen m je
comprends pas qu'on lui fassent ces
reproches
étant donné qu'elle n'a pas sa place je
trouve ça assez injuste voilà annabelle
film j'ai regardé l'émission dansé hier
et j'ai vraiment adoré cette émission je
me sens bien pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
enlevé à christian cordula bon en même
temps hier elle a que 10 faut mettre des
gaines d'aider des culottes hautes et
tout ça donc elle n'a pas fait grand
chose mais le programme vraiment très
très très beau marchand explique mario
et c'est moi qui ait unanimité
merci ça n'a pas fait preuve pour
animatrice à la wii c'est vrai qu'il ya
cinq ans n'avait pas l'image qu'elle a
aujourd'hui elle est tellement identifié
au programme qu'elle fait chaque fois qu
on se dit qu'est ce qu'elle fout là est
donc plein de gens se sont dit qu'est ce
que le soul à témoin avec un plein d'eau
qui se disent de vous demander s'il est
arrivée elle villes celles qui sont ces
gens non mais qui sont ces gens mais
franchement qui sont de l'économie ces
gens là ou pas oui je vous regardez sur
le téléphone non je pense à moi je n'en
voyais pas venir essayer mais tu mets et
si tu es chez toi si tu es chez toi
voilà tu es chez toi est ce que tu te
rappelles de gilles verdez bien sûr bien
sûr c'est que c'est une expérience
incroyable de venir ici je me voyais pas
avoir les papiers ne pas ne pas venir
ne pas venir vous remercier vous
remercie il adore vraiment aux marchés
locaux est si tu cherches un stage
n'importe quoi tu vas chez moi d'accord
merci beaucoup
franchement ça me prendrait mal je
voyais on parlait de mahler j'arrête
tout oui les reproches ils sont surtout
sur ce qu'elle a dit cristina cordula
oui c'est ça exactement quasi du gilbert
des arrive et idées il n'est pas hors
sujet comme vous tous moyens et gilles
verdez il a raison c'est sur ce qu'elle
a dit c'est bien sûr une soeur sa
présence ou pas dans l'émission y'a
aucune rabri aucune émotion mais
l'impression qu'elle reproche froidement
devant un miroir aux gens regardez vous
vous êtes moche vous êtes trop gros si
c'est comme ça mais ça très violent je
comprends parfaitement les reprocher
vous avez été tellement bon sur de
premières interventions que pouvait
encore disparaître de mensonges ça fait
plaisir de vous retrouver oui le premier
c'est pas cristina cordula cristina
cordula elle fait du christina cordula
et s'interdit rien le problème c'est le
concept de l'émission est importuné
précise une émission qui ont même pas
marché on va pas la faire perdre la
garde et a permis aux siens mais elle
connaît
quant à personne c'est normal de les
garder la c1 mais ces craintes ont fait
1 million 700 mille téléspectateurs en
prime sur m6 ce qu'on aime karine
marchand qu'on n'aime pas qu'on ait même
si je pourrai meublé et vous savez que
je suis pro m6 mais là les cherry on dit
ce qu'on voudra c'est pas bon ça n'a pas
marché ça n'a pas marché c'est une
émission qui empruntent des moi j'adore
l'émission mais ya problème c'est que
quand ça marche pas il ya un problème un
moment que nous on a fait des émissions
ainsi que pas marché on savait qu'il ya
un problème
le poème c'est elle emprunte des cônes
aux divertissements qui a comme une
mécanique il ya des intervenants et
qu'on rigole part on donne pas en
spectacle un sujet aussi sensible que
l'obésité c'est des gens dont 60 70 80
kilos à perdre ils auraient dû traiter
différemment exempt de prier pas du tout
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est tout
merci mais vous vous avez toujours
raison mais c'est sur une sanction c'est
que vraiment c'est pas très faible et
nous vous tu parlais de toujours de
divertissement c'est pas vrai c'est
exact
alors que je vous ai dit et je pense
profondément que c'est ça et les études
le prouvent les personnes en surpoids
n'ont pas nécessairement envie de voir
ça ce ne sont pas décidés à se faire
opérer et ceux qui sont pas en surpoids
n'ont aucun intérêt à vous allez j'y
arrive et vous allez l'énervé oui il ya
plein de trucs à dire j'ai de très
belles voix avant vous trouvez merci
c'est parce que j'étais proche orient
merci pousse aussi oui alors moi je suis
pas d'accord avec mes camarades je
trouve une accordina d'avoir son
principal problème c'est d'être grande
immense donc comme elle est grande et
mince elle ne peut pas juger des gens
qui sont en obésité parce qu'on va la
juger et comme aujourd'hui on doit
forcément juger les gens quand on fait
partie de la même communauté
quand on a le même problème là du coup
donc tout ce qu'elle peut dire est
irrecevable et forcément grosso pop
deuxièmement je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec mes camarades quand on
veut perdre du poids ou quand on est en
obésité
excusez moi mais le look c'est très
important de savoir comment on doit
s'habiller quand on est dans la cabine
d'essayage qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre
comme longueur de jupe comme qualité de
tissu et tout ça donc je pense que le
look et l'habit fait partie aussi le
mois la confiance de la confiance en soi
alors on va voir les transformations
d'hier il ya eu une transformation des
participantes sylvie et audrey au regard
des avancées sleeve même si elle tentait
de rester forte
audrey avait du mal à affronter son
image mais aujourd'hui la peau distendu
de son ventre rend l'exercice presque
aussi difficile
sylvie qui ressentait il y a deux ans
une souffrance insupportable quand elle
regarde et son reflet prend à présent
plaisir à s'admirer dans le miroir
à force de détermination sylvie a réussi
à faire de la honte et de l'isolément
social un lointain souvenir
de quoi être optimiste pour l'avenir
sans jamais oublier d'où il vient
oui normal vous êtes un peu dur avec
cristina cordula pascal a aussi elle a
beaucoup de bienveillance oui une façon
de s'exprimer qui viennent à elle que
l'on connaît y a rien de choquant c'est
plutôt gentil mignons les uns viennent
entourer les a aidés elle les a encadrés
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé qu'ils trouvent
ça chantier me news les [ __ ] à poil
devant ces voyeurs la maison mais ça
c'est la wii est le elle souhaite le
faire moi je suis passages entiers
mignon mais ça fait partie des irakiens
en fait pierre castaldi qu'elles ont
alors été la plus pur comme j'aime
celui-là
elle vise donc qu'on me prenait pour
cette punition mais je sais rien de
l'argent il en parle demain alors
moi je suis très clair qu'après le t2t à
bas salaire vous émettez très bien votre
père blessure comme j'aime et je vous
dirai pas 180 milles et autres et
comment tu vas prendre pour baba mon
chéri chéri alors vous allez faire une
pub pour 10kg à gauche oui j'ai fait le
but pour wonderbra non c'est pas vrai
les soutiens gorge pour hommes non mais
c'est vrai que ça arrive et c'est vrai
qu'il arrive ça arrive cela a été
constaté par bender mois n'ont offert
une campagne mondiale
ça va leur coûter à wonder moi ouais on
ne savait pas pourquoi c'est vrai bien
sur quoi vous avec vos centre droit bien
organisés entre pour comme jamais je
vous le dirai pas et en régions est ce
que vous êtes obligés de rester mince
oui j'ai mangé comme j'aime le soir
tombe à masquer frère je crois pas comme
j'aime ils font des loups bien parce que
j'étais vous savez que j'ai enrichi qui
vient tous les matins me peser tous tous
les to les moins pesé bref vous l'avez
soudoyer pas du tout bien la maison il
me pèse quoi vous avez prises et pris
des kilos mais non mais changer de
rester au poids pour aller au bout de
mon contrat
d'accord c'est jusqu'à quand votre
contrat fin juin voilà vous allez signer
combien de temps et comme j'aime mais
écoutez vous faisait de la police ou de
la police des médias vous avez
considérant joie est à la fois précieux
c'est une fourchette ouais ça c'est un
plat c'est plus de veauchette céline les
travées sont pas du tout le drame et
seraient pas délogés la vérité mais pas
du tout
on est en train d arnaque qu'ils ont à
se mentir ou d'en changer là-bas c'est
comme j'aime manger alors bonjour vous
voulez je vous adore j'ai heureusement
louèrent donc cordula la panne chez moi
elle est ni psychologue ni psychiatre
c'est vrai que cette vision de laden
dans le miroir avec la femme à côté qui
était opéré sur site est extrêmement
dérangeant foutez vous de ma gueule
encore une fois est venu au sras
bataille mais c'est comme un teint avec
une vendeuse dans un magasin il mais on
peut pas dire à une dame qui fait tiquer
en surpoids qu'est ce que tu vois
comment tu devenant sa version b je
voudrais juste vous engueuler pas devant
le petit dérangeante effectivement le
mélange des genres est là vient du
divertissement
c'est censé être une émission sérieuse
mais on s'est créé là et ça fait un
mélange compliqué
joris compenser téléspectateurs 1 voilà
on va voir tout de suite cristina
cordula des critiques oui à 38%
non ce mois ci sont plutôt d'accord avec
les pros qu'est-ce qui la corde ou là
comme moi même